the biden administration as basically a
homeland security in the white house
saying these horses are no longer going
to be used to push back migrants who are
trying to come illegally across the
border and it comes after false
allegations that those agents were using
whips and that sparked outrage from
progressives rowdy ballard is the former
border patrol horse coordinator for the
del rio sector and it's really good to
have you here i mean
um so i know a lot about horses i know
that you do too um what is lost by not
having these
men and women be able to do their jobs
on horseback
well the ability to patrol down there
more effectively for one i mean it's a
the horse is a great tool
we've used for almost 100 years now and
and with that gone it's going to be
harder to patrol that area
and what did you think about the
accusations
that
these border patrol agents were whipping
these migraines i mean the the to me the
photograph is obviously misunderstood
reporters and apparently people in the
white house and the administration don't
understand how horses work in terms of
rains
what kind of damage does that do to the
border patrol agents who were doing
their jobs
well it's frustrating uh they've been
trained a certain way and uh when people
uh
look at what they're doing and interpret
another way it's it's it could be
frustrating no we don't we don't have
whips we don't carry whips and uh they
they weren't whipping them it was just a
form of
a pressure and release it was a tense
situation the horses uh were a little
reluctant to uh
do the job that the uh agents were
asking and uh you know it's a
twirling the reigns uh was a just
another tool they used to get the horses
to do what they're asking them
you know roddy you talk about
frustrating you know 35 years ago my
first job was in yuma arizona and
broadcasting we rode with these guys in
the yuba sector they are the best at
doing this job better than anybody and
it's got to be frustrating when the
homeland security secretary is literally
on monday i want to play this back and
forth between the border patrol chief
and the homeland security secretary
talking about monday what they thought
about the video watch
patrol units down here are going to play
an integral part in the security
response operating in
the riverine environment on horseback is
a difficult situation and trying to
making control of those horses so we do
not get in a position where we injure a
migrant we are going to investigate the
facts to ensure uh that the situation is
as we understand it to be
yeah on on monday he was saying you know
this video looked fine it looked
appropriate and on tuesday because of
the bandwagon all the democrats
screaming bloody murder all of a sudden
myocris jumps on the bandwagon that's
got to be frustrating for the secretary
of the homeland security to to take that
position change what's your thought
about it
yeah it's uh it's frustrating for the
guys in the field as well
i mean they they were asked to do a job
and uh
they did it to the best their abilities
and now they're getting
they're suffering the whiplash from this
yeah indeed and in fact just to wrap
this up on a note that
not lighter but i have to tell you i
have to read this tweet for you this is
from the national fraternal order of
police and they say for all you twitter
warriors out there these are not whips
and no border patrol agents are not
whipping people they are rain so stay
with us here like a steering wheel is
used to drive a car the reins are used
to drive the horse thanks for coming to
our ted talk which i thought was a
pretty good way to do it rowdy thank you
so much for being here today and
we'll keep an eye on it the
administration says they're going to do
an investigation and to see what will
happen to these border patrol agents
falsely accused
of whipping migrants at the border rowdy
thank you so much
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now